comme on dit à peu près 50 millions de
10 ces salons tu as chanté dans tous les
pays du monde sauf dans le tien tu n'es
jamais retourné en âge avait jamais de
quand date la dernière demande
officielle que tu ais faite pour pour
retourner chanter là bas ou même pour
retourner en touriste je n'ai jamais
fait de demande officielle
on n'a jamais fait ni le gouvernement
algérien ni moi même on apprend encore
fait le ce qu'il faut mais ça va
peut-être venir un jour je sais pas en
tout cas si ça doit rapprocher des êtres
humains
je me sacrifierai je le ferai quelles
analyses tu portes sur la situation
actuelle en algérie
c'est à dire le premier tour le fils le
deuxième tour qui n'a pas lieu
les chars et quand moi je pense que
lorsqu'il y à un seul parti dans un pays
et une seule religion c'est trop c'est à
dire qu' il devrait avoir beaucoup de
religions et beaucoup de parties et
c'est à cause de cela qu'il ya des
problèmes
alors tu es en étudiant ta vie pour
préparer cette émission je me suis
aperçu que tu avais pris beaucoup de
risques parce que tu as été par exemple
sur la liste noire d'une organisation
terroriste palestinienne
tu étais obligé de voyager aux états
unis sous un faux nom à une époque tu
vis ça comment au départ quand quand on
prend le journal le matin puis consorts
on voit que
carlos annonce que je suis condamné à
mort par les terroristes palestiniens
ça fait quelque chose et au fil des
temps sont passés des événements
absolument extraordinaires telles que
par exemple la rencontre avec le
président sadate où il y avait 150 mille
palestiniens qui m'attendait là-bas au
caire et je dois dire que j'ai eu là bas
un entretien avec des représentants des
palestiniens peut m'aider palestiniens
dur ne croyait il faut pas croire que
c'était des gens faciles à rencontrer
ils ont tenu à saluer mon courage et
parce qu'il savait que j'étais un homme
engagé pour mentionner c'est à dire pro
israélien pour défendre la cause de mes
frères israéliens mais aussi engagé pour
le combat de la paix et ils savent que
je suis un homme de paix et ils ont
complètement levé la condamnation à mort
kim kim chi chi pesé sur moi et depuis
tout va bien si on règlerait le problème
comment au moyen-orient moi j'ai déjà
réglé le problème des roms et gens du
soleil y tu ferais que quelle partition
de la région du fait d'abord peut pas
trouver une solution comme ça mais
d'abord je suis sûr que si les
palestiniens enlevés de leur charte le
la phrase qui dit qu'il faut que israël
soit complètement détruit déjà et
beaucoup de choses qui seraient arrangés
alors non seulement indésirable dans ton
pays en algérie mais dans ton notre pays
la france puisque en 88
tu n'as pas pu chanter à marignane parce
qu'on peut reprocher des pieds-noirs
là-bas te reprocher son soutien à
françois mitterrand je ne doute pas une
seule seconde de ma sincérité de mon
apprenti sith et de ma crédibilité
et puis de mon ma solidarité vis-à-vis
de mes frères art qui est bien noir et
ceux qui pratiquent ce genre d'action
sont des gens d'extrême droite qui comme
prétexte se servent de certains juifs et
même de certains pieds noirs pour
arriver à leurs fins ils disent voilà il
ya même des pieds noirs quidam qu'enrico
macias ya même des juristes qui n'aiment
pas enrico macias
donc votez pour nous aimer ça on va pas
tomber dans leur piège on ne tombera
jamais dans leur piège dis-moi enrico là
où ça s'est pas arrangée du tout c'est
quand tu es allé soutenir tapis avec et
jetèrent est géniale idée quand même un
nom pourquoi pas parce que les mails ils
n'étaient pas encore très content non
plus parce que ça faisait un peu y avait
non seulement ça et mon alice elle
faisait moins services - chez moi
premièrement je suis crédible à tout
point de vue pour moi parce que je me
suis engagé avec tapis parce que tapie
c'est le premier qui a osé avoir l'écran
connaissent je m'excuse d'aller
affronter le pen tout le monde a peur de
l'hôtel alors
continuez oui j'ai suivi tapis parce que
je suis un petit peu je fais partie de
la communauté juive tapis les pas juif
si il me demande à moi de l'aider pour
combattre le pen et que moi je me défile
il va dire ah bon alors ils ont raison
de ce qu'ils font c'est ce qu'ils font
aux gîtes et ben non moi je marche avec
tapis pour ça et pour mitterrand sur
comment ferais moi je trouve que la
france a eu la chance d'avoir un grand
président